foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the show this episode is
brought to you by good ranchers get
great meat at a secure price and 30
bucks off your order with my code
Knowles go to goodranchers.com use my
code Knowles today we've got a really
really important clip of Joe Biden
rambling incoherently that we'll get to
in just a little bit but I don't want to
move too fast off this
[Music]
now speak
at weird sex stuff
there's a lot of you know there's a lot
of stuff that I'm not allowed to talk
about on YouTube anymore so if you watch
this show on YouTube you've got to head
on over or sometimes to hear the first
time I don't know first 10 minutes of my
show you got to head on over to daily
wire plus where you got to go to m
Knowles show at Twitter we'll post the
whole thing over there where you got to
go to the RSS feed at Apple podcast
Spotify wherever you get your podcasts
but there are certain weird sex stuff
that at least for now I think we're
still allowed to talk about on YouTube
that would be
weird sex stuff involving Hunter Biden
Hunter Biden we'll get to the latest
Hunter Biden scandal
a real deep Scandal of public interest
not just drugs and hookers and that kind
of stuff but something that really gets
to the corruption of his family and his
father
but first
I've gone a little lighter on Hunter
Biden than a number of conservatives
have they just Hammer every picture
every crack pipe falling out of his
mouth in every hookeries video in
himself with and they're making fun of
his drug addiction and I've tried not to
do that because I don't think that
people ought to be judged for the bad
stuff that they used to do especially if
they've cleaned themselves up there but
for the grace of God go all of us
everybody's done bad things all have sin
had fallen short of the glory of God so
I'm not going to make fun of him for
that I've got plenty of friends who have
been addicts and drunks and everything
so I'm not going to really hit him too
much for that
I don't think people should be judged
for the terrible things they used to do
I think that they should be judged for
the terrible things that they're doing
right now
so that they can correct those things
and Hunter Biden
currently a huge scumbag
forget about what he did on Skid Row
forget about the hookers and the drugs
and everything what this guy is doing
right now he he took his baby mama
London Roberts to court to try to reduce
the child support payments that he is
sending to his daughter Navy is this
daughter Navy that he will not
acknowledge he will not meet this poor
little girl is four years old her father
openly hates her and her grandfather is
the president of the United States and
he refuses to acknowledge her as well
and her her grandfather Joe Biden oh
good old nice guy Joe that devout
Catholic Joe Biden he puts up stockings
at the White House his his this little
girl's grandmother or step-grandmother
Dr Jill Biden oh sweet old Dr Jill who
writes children's books she refuses to
acknowledge this poor girl too girls
four years old they put up stockings at
the White House of all the Biden
grandkids except for one
and then this Dirtbag Hunter Biden goes
into court says I want to pay my baby
mama significantly less money this is a
guy who's shaking down every corrupt
oligarch around the world in Ukraine in
China from this guy this guy who's made
millions and millions of dollars tens of
millions of dollars and he won't pay
child support to or he won't pay a
serious amount of Child Support to his
baby mama and then he in court
tries to insist that his own daughter
isn't allowed to use his last name
that that they've got to change the
little girl's last name or stop her from
using the Biden name he's so ashamed of
this four-year-old girl it's such
scumbag behavior and it's from Hunter
Biden who I guess we expect that from
from this idea that Hunter he's cleaned
up you know the support of a loving
father that really got him over his
addiction now he's a complete dirt bag
today and he's doing something worse
today than anything he's done in the
past which is hurt his little daughter
and scandalize her
and and this is exactly what the
millstone verse of the Bible is about
and and and Hunter's Dirtbag father Joe
Biden's doing virtually the same thing
as pres imagine you're a little girl
you're four years old you're starting to
become kind of conscious you're starting
to be aware of things and what you were
told every single day is that your
father hates you and your grandfather
the president of the United States hates
you too because you're not good enough
to be acknowledged in fact they're going
to take you to court so that you can't
use their last name which is your last
name because your
their their daughter and granddaughter
it's just so awful and Hunter doesn't
get nearly enough grief for this and Joe
Biden doesn't get enough grief for this
either
yeah Hunter engage in all sorts of
colorful awful behavior and
I guess he doesn't do that anymore who
knows maybe he still does and yeah he's
a corrupt public official or he's the
corrupt son of a public official and
seems to be the bag man for the whole
Biden family and that's really bad and
it's
kind of run-of-the-mill corruption at a
much grander scale than we've seen
before but I don't know this one gets me
a lot worse him the Biden family acting
like a a mafia family going around and
shaking down corrupt people around the
world selling American influence that's
worse as a matter of public corruption
but it bothers me less than this I just
think about that four I mean it's
because I have young kids do you think
about that four-year-old girl
who who is whose father and grandfather
hate her so much that they'll take her
to court to to avoid acknowledging her
just just disgusting stuff from an
absolutely disgusting family that should
change their behavior as soon as
possible but there there is an aspect of
public corruption here too which is
that we got another Hunter Biden text so
you had that first one which was Hunter
Biden shaking down a Communist Party of
china-affiliated business
executive and saying hey send me money
I'm sitting next to my dad my dad's the
big guy over here and we're gonna hold a
grudge and we're gonna make China hurt
and we're gonna make you hurt we're will
be influence of the United States if you
don't send us a payoff now and the Biden
Camp the White House is insisting that
this these were just the rantings of an
addict who was lying who was desperate
you know trying to compare Hunter Biden
to some junkie on the street who goes
and steals his grandma's VCR or
something like that you know a guy who's
just lying and making things up even
though you read the texts they're pretty
specific they seem fairly Lucid for a
guy who's smoking a bunch of crack and
in throws of addiction well now we got a
second text
asking for 10 million bucks from a CCP
linked associate
and you know if this guy just put down
all the stuff that was bad for him and
if he had just started consuming things
that were really good for him he would
have had a much better life he would
have he would have been consuming good
things like good ranchers right now head
on over to goodranchers.com he's promo
code Knowles as our great nation's
birthday approaches we are coming
together as Americans and savoring the
delicious Taste of homegrown American
made meat our friends at good Ranchers
have the best Quality Meats that you've
ever tasted and they only sell meat that
was raised here in the USA from now
until Independence Day good ranchers
will be offering the best deals to give
you freedom from the meat aisle from rib
eyes New York strips all-natural Burgers
to the most delicious chicken you could
ever want good ranchers has something
for everyone plus right now you will get
30 off with our code Knowles at
goodranchers.com if you are looking for
a way to wow your family during the 4th
of July check out their website recipe
of the Texas style chopped patty melt
I test this out because I want to make
sure that I'm not just imagining it I've
tested out good ranchers meat at dinner
parties with friends with with a number
of people they all agree it's just
absolutely top of the line the price is
shockingly low what are you waiting for
let the mouth-watering aroma of
American-made meat fill the air bringing
Joy Unity intellectual flavors to your
celebrations goodranchors.com use code
nulls you get 30 bucks off any box
codenolsgoodranchors.com
goodranchers.com American Meat delivered
so we got we got this new text here
what's the new text
this is uh days after we we get the
WhatsApp text from 2017 about Joe Biden
sitting next to him
well now in a message dated August 3rd
2017. Hunter tells uh gong when Kevin
dong CCP Affiliated business associate
that he wants to quit squabbling over
peanuts and settle on a firm deal by
putting quote this to bed tonight and
get to work I'm tired of this Kevin I
can make five million dollars in salary
at any law firm in America
and why is it because Hunter Biden is
such a genius expert at the law I don't
think so I think it's because even if
you're working in a law firm in America
he'd be peddling his father's influence
but instead he became even more corrupt
and even greedier and he tried to sell
his father's influence overseas
with the knowledge of his father by the
way Hunter writes very simple 10 million
dollars per annum budget to use to
further the interest of the JV of this
of this business interest this move to 5
million is completely new to me and is
not acceptable obviously
so he's saying you only want to pay me
five million dollars a year to sell
American influence I don't think so
Buster you got to double that he says if
you think this is about money it's not
the bidens are the best I know at doing
exactly what the chairman wants from
this partnership let's not quibble over
peanuts
five million dollars in peanuts very
expensive peanuts
but the bidens or the bet not Hunter
Biden not even just Joe Biden the Biden
family
because this is not
a a new kind of behavior that cropped up
when Hunter Biden found the crack pipe
this is behavior that the Biden family
including Joe Biden's brother including
the whole family has engaged in for
decades now and so it's not surprising
what do we take away from this we take
away
that if you think Joe Biden has not been
involved in his family's corruption I
have got a bridge in Rehoboth Beach
Delaware to sell you but
this gets to the heart of a lot of the
squabbling on the GOP side over 2024 and
relitigating 2020 which is
a family that does this a family that
sells American influence for millions
and millions of dollars brazenly openly
in WhatsApp messages Joe Biden bragging
about it at the Council of Foreign
Relations I went to Ukraine and I told
that prosecutor if you don't if you
don't fire that prosecutor I'm gonna
withhold a billion dollars in American
Aid and you stop you you fire that
prosecutor who's investigating the
company that's paying off my son a ton
of money for me to Peddle American
influence he's bragging about it he's
open about it it's all there and
transparent and you're telling me
that a family
that engages in that kind of public
corruption and a party that sanctions
that kind of public corruption wouldn't
steal an election oh yeah we just found
what 300 mail-in ballots in a in a
locker in Michigan from 2020 but there
are a lot of lockers in Michigan but
there are a lot of lockers in
Pennsylvania and Arizona and Georgia I
bet there are a lot
you're telling me
that a party where the the two of the
three most prominent families in the
last 20 years the clintons and the
bidens the Obamas are corrupt too they
come out of Chicago machine politics but
in this case we're talking about selling
American influence top dollar engaging
in really corrupt activity and we got we
got the bidens and the Clinton is dead
to rights at least you telling me that
party wouldn't steal an election give me
a break
this is going to be the real issue for
me and I I need a GOP candidate to
explain to me not how you're going to
lock up the Border though that would be
good not how you're going to turn the
economy around
it's actually probably straightforward
enough not even how you're going to
wield government power to fix the
education system and the culture and I
want to know all that
I want to know how you're going to
overcome the Democrats rigging the
election like they did in 2020. and I I
need Trump to explain that to me I need
this antis to explain that to me we you
know we're we're in the midst of the
chrysosons the Chris Christie
Renaissance I need Chris Christie to
explain this to me and Vivek and Mike
Pence and whoever else is running okay
and you got to explain that to me
because
right now the the Democrats feel that
they've got a very solid electoral asset
in the way that they've rigged the
system and when you want a solid asset
you got to check out Birch gold right
now text Knowles to 98 98 98 central
banks in countries such as China China
India and Australia have announced they
are beginning to explore transitioning
to a digital currency the Federal
Reserve has been contemplating the same
for the U.S with the digital currency
the government could track every single
purchase you make officials could even
prohibit you from purchasing certain
products or easily freeze or seize part
or all of your money Times Like These
are a great reminder to diversify a
portion of your savings into gold you
can do that with the help of Birch gold
they are the guys that I get my gold
from so do thousands of other concern
Savers Birch gold will help you convert
an existing Ira or 401K into an IRA in
Gold you won't pay a penny out of pocket
when currencies fail gold is a safe
haven how much more time does the Dollar
have protect your savings with gold
Birch gold has an A plus rating with the
Better Business Bureau thousands of Abby
customers text Knowles Canada wlas to 98
98 98 get your free info kit on gold if
a central bank digital currency becomes
a reality it will be nice to have some
gold to depend on text nulls to 98.98 98
speaking of
[Music]
degenerate sort of places that have been
destroyed by bad political decisions
San Francisco just hosted Ron DeSantis
or rather Rhonda Sanders chose to go to
San Francisco as he makes his campaign
for presidency not just about a handful
of States but about coast to coast and a
major cultural change here's what the
governor said
you look around uh the city is not
vibrant anymore it's really collapsed
because of leftist policies and these
policies have caused people to flee this
area they don't prosecute criminals like
they do in most parts of the country and
the wreckage has really really been sad
to see and so I've seen so many
businesses boarded up I've seen so much
uh riffraff just running around and it
just shows you these policies matter
leadership matters they are doing it
wrong here
I really like this look
I like this look of Ron DeSantis being
out in The Fray in front of this
graffitied up building all this trash on
the street in California what's he doing
in California I like that
I wish we saw more of the delivery here
I wish we saw more of the interaction
uh what what I've heard about this trip
is that people are coming up to DeSantis
in California and saying hey man we
support you you know
regular good sort of ordinary American
people that we all like and support the
crazy Libs they all were yelling at
desantas but the normal nice people and
the First Responders and the cool guys
they all like DeSantis
so I'd like to see more of that I want
to see more interaction
want to see DeSantis out in the world
the knock on DeSantis right now
is that he's a little too stiff he's not
good enough with people he doesn't have
enough Riz you know to use my Zoomer
lingo
that he he's he's running
there's a little bit of a I don't know
focused group tested type of
establishment candidate and he shouldn't
run that way and he doesn't need to run
that way so put him out there yes send
him to San Francisco and let's see him
in that Fray that's something that that
Trump has that that uh DeSantis really
needs to to go after best I've seen him
but we should go even further down that
line if we're talking about a DeSantis
kind of campaign
now I got bad news for DeSantis which is
that Trump continues to dominate in the
polls and he's getting stronger and
stronger in the polls there's a poll
right now out of Quinnipiac that shows
Trump not only beating the rest of the
GOP field by law which he's doing but
Trump beating Biden and and not just
Trump beating Biden at the national
level which uh the other night we were
on Backstage and I was trying to explain
to my friend and colleague Ben Shapiro
that Trump is a lot stronger than than
the people who don't like Trump or
letting on and I said well one example
is that Trump is beating Biden in the
polls and he says well those are just
National polls and National polls don't
matter because the elections come down
to just a handful of states and not even
a whole lot of counties well now we have
a poll out from Quinnipiac which shows
Trump beating Biden in Pennsylvania
Pennsylvania is supposed to be Joe
Biden's home turf good old Scranton Joe
and Trump is beating him there head to
head
47-46 so it's close
but Trump is still ahead there so from
the argument
that Trump can't win
is falling apart
they are it I always thought it was a
silly argument because he won in 2016.
so the people who say Trump will never
ever win is going to destroy the GOP
they were wrong in 2016. but yeah okay
he was not able to remain the president
after the 2020 election how's that for a
diplomatic way of putting it uh and and
he is off-putting to a lot of people and
he doesn't need to do a better job of
appealing to people who are a little
more Centrist and a little bit more in
the middle I'm not denying any of that
it's just Biden looks so terrible right
now and Trump looks so unfairly
persecuted that even in a place like
Pennsylvania Trump is currently leading
so now one of the big anti-trump lines
in the primary is gone
it's gone on the idea that he can't win
it's going on the idea that well the
national polls don't matter yeah maybe
the national polls don't tell you
everything but the state polls do and
even in the contentious Battleground
Staples Trump's looking pretty good so
what is DeSantis going to say to this
well the DeSantis campaign pitch is
going to be
that
Trump had the right idea but he failed
in the execution and I'm going to be the
better Trump most of us in this room
voted to drain the swamp twice I talked
to us specifically about why you're the
right candidate to folks in New
Hampshire to come behind in this primary
to drain the Swap and get it done this
time as opposed to the other choice it's
a great great question and what's your
name
okay thanks Mark so the question is and
I remember these rallies in 2016. it was
exciting drain the swamp I also remember
lock her up lock her up right and then
two weeks after the election oh don't
forget about it forget I ever said that
no no no one thing you'll get from me if
I tell you I'm going to do something I'm
not just saying that for an election and
there are promises I could make that may
help me marginally politically that I
don't know that I could that I could
necessarily follow through on so I will
not make that and I think the idea of
draining the swamp in some respects it I
think it misses it a little bit because
if you we didn't drain it it's worse
today than it's ever been by far uh and
that's a sad Testament to to the state
affairs of our country but even if
you're successful at draining it the
next guy can just refill it so I want to
break the swamp that's really what we
need to do
that's a sophisticated point
which is that not only do you need to
fire the bad people but you need to
change the structure
that that is causing the problems in the
first place it's all good and it all
comes down to this idea that DeSantis is
Trump 2.0 better bigger faster stronger
more precise better at wielding politics
Trump's big strength was that he's a
political Outsider and and doesn't
really know how Washington Works
DeSantis does get how Washington Works
he was a congressman he's been an
effective Governor so he's going to take
trumpism and really put it into effect
that's the line
and it's not going to work that's not
going to be and if that is all the
campaign is about then the SanDisk
campaign is not going to win
because it's New Coke versus Coca-Cola
classic
Coca-Cola classic which is the Coca-Cola
that we all have today people really
like it and then
some 30 40 years ago was it that long at
this point yeah I guess it is
the Coca-Cola decides they've got a new
Coke formula and they bring it out and
it's a complete disaster and they have
to return to the old Coke formula well
why did they bring it out was it just
some Rogue marketing executive who
screwed things up no they tested New
Coke over and over and over again and
when people were given blind taste tests
of New Coke versus the old Coke people
preferred the new Coke
but when the blindfold came off and they
knew
what the brands were and they they had a
choice between that old thing the OG and
the new and improved version
they picked the original
and that's exactly what's going on in
the GOP Primary right now you could say
that DeSantis is better at wielding
power and implementing these things and
he's more philosophically and
ideologically coherent and he
understands politics better and you go
down the whole Litany of compliments
yeah that might be true but the way that
people respond to that the way that
psychology works is that
people like that original thing you know
and Trump is an American original so if
the the Santa's campaign is going to be
effective it's going to need something
in addition to I'm just the bigger
better Trump
now you might have been one of the tens
of millions of people who watch
Netflix's hit show making a murderer if
so then you're going to love daily wire
plus this new exclusive 10-part
docu-series with Candace Owens
convicting a murderer coming this summer
whether it's exposing black lives matter
or certain fallacies in the healthcare
industry regarding covid Candace Owens
has never been afraid to challenge The
Narrative she will find the truth
wherever it leads when Candace found out
that key facts may have been omitted in
Netflix a series
she set out to uncover the real story
behind the notorious Stephen Avery case
the end result is convicting a murderer
you will not want to miss it right now
there's never been a better time to
become a daily wire plus member sign up
now for convicting a murderer you will
receive an early bird discount of 25 off
your daily wire Plus Membership you will
also get all of the other premium
content from daily wire plus including
the greatest Li ever sold what is a
woman and the largest collection of
content from Dr Jordan B Peterson join
now at dailywire.com subscribe to become
a member and see the truth when it
finally comes out my favorite comment
yesterday is from Firefly Ivory YT who
says my goodness CNN is grabbing at the
lowest apples on the tree at this point
anything to try and catch him to get
Trump to have the walls closing in of
course
but that's what they've been doing since
2016.
it's not even that they've run out of
good things to go after and now they're
making stuff up
in 2016 when Barack Obama's doj and FBI
illegally spied on Trump's campaign to
try to suppress the political opposition
they just made up the pre-text set of
whole cloth
the whole thing has been a big fiction
from the beginning
now
speaking of New Coke and old Coke and
political campaigns and innovation
Mr Davies sent me this clip yesterday
and I didn't even want to include it but
but we have to we have to because what
do they say they say politics is
Downstream of culture which is half true
and a culturist downstream of religion
and you're seeing and intensifying of
religious debate and
when we talk about religion and
Christianity some people don't even know
what we're talking about anymore
especially this Priestess from some
liberal heretical sect of
pseudo-christianity who decided to
change the Creed of the religion I
invite you to rise in body or spirit
and let us confess our faith today in
the words of the sparkle Creed
I believe in the non-binary god whose
pronouns are plural I believe in Jesus
Christ their child who wore a fabulous
tunic all right enough enough turn it
off sorry don't can't I'm not getting
through it not getting through it not
gonna you know maybe a free speech
absolutist would would say well we need
to listen to that because the answer to
bad ideas is it's just more speechers
nope not going to hear that heretical
Blasphemous claptrap but you get the
point that's more than I made it through
listening to yesterday when I said I'd
put it in the show
what is the point of church
if that's your church
if your version of going to church is
going to a building and looking at some
ridiculous woman dressing up playing
Halloween pretend like a priest with
invalid holy orders reciting a Creed
that amounts to nothing more than uh the
same rainbow pride flag stuff that
you're getting in every TV commercial
from all the major brands in the entire
culture from the government from the
White House from your teachers from your
boss from the HR manager from every
single thing in the culture what the
hell is the point of going to church
we go to church
to escape
this world
to look Beyond this world this is a
Fallen World governed by principalities
and powers and spiritual wickedness in
high places and so when we go to church
when we go to Holy Mass we get a little
foretaste of Heaven
and we
check the worldliness at the door and we
do something else especially when we're
when we're witnessing the holy sacrifice
of the mass and the sacrifice of our
Lord and Savior Jesus Christ not with
all the fabulous Sparkle whatever
nonsense that she's pretending that
Christianity is it's amazing that these
people are so insistent that everybody
respected their preferred and inaccurate
pronouns but this woman won't respect
God's pronouns that he makes rather
clear in the Bible
what's what's the point that is
offensive to me to hear that
it's very sad and silly for the people
who are attending that church and for
this poor misguided Priestess
but what's the point what a wait just go
to brunch you know just if you're going
to engage in weird Sac religious
nonsense then you should do whatever
other atheist white girl Millennial does
and just go to yoga and then go have
champagne brunch on Sunday and call that
your church
but to go and pretend no I it's just the
lips do this all the time they want the
appearance of the thing but they don't
want the substance of the thing
the sort of people who they they drink
diet coke they have meatless hamburgers
they do they want all the trappings of
good stuff without any any of the meat
of it they want the appearance of church
without the meaning it was I think it
was niebuhr who had a great line you saw
this coming in the 20th century and he
said the people
in modern religion want a god without
wrath leading a people without sin into
a kingdom without judgment through the
administrations of a Christ without a
cross
now they're taking it to a God and his
son without pronouns
without any identity okay well then
you're gonna if you're losing the
identity of being himself of the man who
says of the god that says I am that I am
then you're losing the whole religion
speaking of incoherent rambling
our this is breaking news breaking stop
the presses Joe Biden is rambling
incoherently again I've long said and I
mean this
I was on Tibetan Plateau with Xi Jinping
I traveled 17 000 miles from here I've
spoke with him more than any other state
because it started when I was vice
president and president who was the
president and he was the vice president
we knew what was on second was
inappropriate I don't know
but I I spent a lot of days ago first
base I met alone with him just he and I
and a simultaneous interpreter 68 times
68 hours
68th time more than 68 hours how do I
turned in all my notes that's got I got
my 68 68 hours and 68 no 68 68 times
more has 525 600 minutes how do you
measure how do you measure a year Jack
if you measure in inches or centimeters
Jack that's the metric system one's the
English system with the English
abandoned the standard system now you
use the metric system
what's uh what's a meter meters in a
poem Jack come on Corn Pop
there's a report out
that Joe Biden is not sleeping very well
and he's got breathing problems when he
sleeps and he has sleep apnea and he's
on a CPAP machine and that explains not
only why he appears Dazed and Confused
but also why there's some markings on
his face now they're saying the markings
are from the CPAP machine a lot of
people use a CPAP machine it's it's a
machine that injects some air a very low
pressure flow of air into your nose so
you don't suffocate while you sleep and
have that disturb your sleep and make
you even more Dazed and Confused though
some people have suggested that the
marks on Biden's face are not really
consistent with a CPAP mask my
grandfather worse a mask many many moons
ago when he was still alive
and I don't I don't know I guess
I don't take the White House at their
word for anything but whatever it is the
guy is not well
the guy is not well at all and this is
not only acceptable in our current
system but it's actually kind of an
advantage
because
the expectations for this White House
are extraordinarily low and because the
liberal establishment gets to prove gets
to actually not just hide this or
downplay it but shove your face in the
fact that the country is not currently
being run by a president going back a
hundred years going back more than 100
years to Woodrow Wilson you've had
liberals and progressives say that the
presidency is too big now for any one
man the modern challenges are too big
for our constitutional system of
government
and so you have to replace that
constitutional system with a technocracy
and with a liberal establishment that
really becomes the supreme law of the
land more so than the congressman more
so than the Senators more so than the
president and the judges even and the
Constitution liberalism is that supreme
law of the land and obviously we've all
seen in recent years how when there is a
conflict between liberalism and
democracy liberalism always wins when
the people elect Donald Trump that's a
risk to democracy if they were really
talking about democracy that wouldn't be
possible but when they say democracy
they mean liberalism when when a
right-winger like Victor or bond in
Hungary or Georgia Maloney in Italy or a
referendum like brexit in the United
Kingdom when that's passed by the people
that's a threat to democracy how because
it's only about
liberalism so the question for us is if
if we want to take down liberalism if we
believe that democracy is the best way
to do it how can we ensure that our
voices are heard and these very corrupt
very proud people are not just going to
rig the whole system against us now
speaking of technical Feats and
advancements today is
technology to Thursday
is it is that I need a I need a better
alliteration for the day
The Producers have a challenge for me
which is they've used these new weird
creepy image apps to create AI generated
images and you and I have to guess the
prompt the rest of the show continues
now you don't want to miss it become a
member use code Knowles at checkout for
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
oh